we've got another update on the
Activision and Microsoft deal
investigation as well as silent hill and
Disney news
the competition and markets Authority
has so far expressed a number of
concerns related to Microsoft and
Activision Blizzard's deal one concern
is how it has the potential to have a
major impact on Sony if Activision
Blizzard content is made exclusive to
Xbox in response to the cma's decision
to enter a second phase of Investigation
Microsoft highlighted footnote
references to the company's gaming CEO
Phil Spencer that said quote the
agreement between Activision Blizzard
and Sony includes restrictions on the
ability of Activision Blizzard to place
Call of Duty titles on Game Pass for a
number of years Spencer had also
confirmed this in a previous interview
and has promised to keep the Call of
Duty franchise on PlayStation for years
Beyond Sony's existing contract with
Activision Sony has criticized this
promise and says that Call of Duty will
only be available for three more years
on Playstation after the current deal
ends the preliminary findings from this
second phase of Investigation will be
released in January with the final
report being released by March 1st the
approval of this deal is taking way
longer than I expected but I mean at the
end of the day I guess that's a good
thing and that's definitely not a
complaint especially as someone like me
who's platform agnostic like I don't
care at all if Call of Duty ends up
being exclusive to Xbox because I'm
still going to be able to play but
that's selfish of me because I know that
this type of thing is going to affect
Gamers who have a very tight budget and
who cannot afford to maybe jump ship on
Playstation if they've already bought
into that ecosystem and go over to Xbox
and it'll also inevitably hurt the
pockets of Sony if they don't get that
like day one PlayStation Call of Duty
money that they're used to at the end of
the day Call of Duty is going to end up
on Game Pass it's if if this deal gets
approved Call of Duty is going to end up
on Game Pass and what that looks like we
don't know yet but in some form or
another it will so like Modern Warfare 2
for example would not end up on Game
Pass all of the other ones would and
then next year when Call of Duty
Advanced Warfare 2 comes out then Modern
Warfare 2 goes into Game Pass and so on
and so forth just my opinion take it how
you will but that's enough about Million
Dollar Deals let's talk about Silent
Hill after months of speculation in
reports Konami officially confirmed its
Silent Hill 2 remake during a video
presentation the game which opened the
presentation with an impressive trailer
looks to be rebuilt from the ground up
while still keeping the essence of the
2001 original intact Silent Hill 2 is in
development at blooper team and is a
PlayStation 5 console exclusive and
lastly let's talk about what I'm most
excited about today scar is now
available in Disney Dream my Valley a
new set of star path rewards are also
available that will let you earn
Halloween themed clothes and decorations
to give your version of dream life
Valley a spooky twist the update also
includes multiple bug fixes for minor
elements like Mickey's weird eyes and
lightning flashes to game breaking bugs
I'll leave a link to all of the patch
notes in the description below and in
the comments tell me your favorite
Disney villain mine is definitely scar
thus the excitement
foreign